[Applause]
if you had to invest your money in
another country I'm sure Venezuela
wouldn't even be on the list right well
give you a Chinese government it does
not agree with you China agrees to
invest 20 billion dollars in Venezuela
to help offset effects of oil price
slump but hold on just a second because
this is not only about China have you
ever heard of Goldman Sachs it's one of
those banks that symbolizes American
capitalism that its purest well they too
saw a lot of business opportunities in
maduras Venezuela Goldman buys 2.8
billion dollars worth of Venezuelan
bonds and an uproar begins yes you heard
that right well Venezuela is having one
of the worst economic catastrophe
humanity has ever witnessed they keep
making deals with the world's biggest
investors this is why it despite the
scarcity the extreme poverty and the
hyperinflation Nicolas Maduro is buying
state-of-the-art weapons to maintain an
army that almost in nobody could attack
an army that has over 5,000 rockets that
were manufactured in Russia in October
of this year that's 2017
Maduro met with Vladimir Putin to buy
weapons
[Music]
meanwhile Venezuela is also the biggest
partner that China has in the region
they have received way more Chinese
money than any other Latin American
country all right so now you might be
wondering well what's the point of all
of this well finance wise China is
pretty blind to ideology and of sin goes
for those American banks their only goal
is to make money but a first sighs I
mean Venezuela it doesn't exactly look
like a great place to do business so how
did Venezuela come to the attention of
so many investors I mean where is the
deal here well today we are going to
answer all of those questions but before
we do let's take a look back at the
history a risky bet okay so here's some
advice if you ever want to become a
dictator in your country and repress
your opponents and torture your many
political foes
there is something you absolutely need
and yes of course that is money yeah
normal citizens can die from starvation
that your police in your army cannot
miss a single payday this is the biggest
problem for enough therawtarian.com
presidents his biggest problem is if the
army decides to strike against it
[Music]
but if you've been following visual
politic for a long time you know that
Venezuela has almost no private
companies say there's not much money to
be collected in taxes further oil
exports are no longer profitable since
the oil prices went down in 2012 in
other words his only way to pay for this
whole repressive apparatus is by getting
loans on the international market
but hold on just a second because things
are not as easy as they seem Venezuela
is a country with terrible economic
problems this means if you lends the
money chances are you're never going to
get it back this is why we say that
Venezuelan bonds are a very high risk
investments and while what two countries
do when investors don't trust them
well they raise the interest rate and
this is why Venezuelan bonds have a
yield of over ten and twelve percent
while a German bonds which is way more
reliable doesn't surpass 0.5 percent all
right so well what does all of this mean
let's imagine we invest a thousand US
dollars in Venezuela bonds to be paid in
10 years with an interest of 10 percent
theoretically the Venezuelan government
is expected to give us back those
thousand dollars that we led them but in
the meantime who receive $100 every year
as an interest payment well
yes I probably guess we're thinking
right now that sounds like a pretty
great business well do not get excited
just yet
as we said before Venezuela has a pretty
high chance of default if the
governments of Caracas the capital of
Venezuela declares bankruptcy in say two
years we're going to have lost 80% of
our investment this is why despite the
high interest rates Nicolas Maduro has
found it harder and harder to sell his
bonds and well this explains news like
this Goldman Sachs Venezuela bond
purchase sparks anger it paid about
eight hundred and sixty five million
dollars for 2.8 billion dollars worth of
bonds alright alright so what does this
mean well it means Goldman Sachs bought
Venezuelan bonds for a third of their
value in other words theoretically the
governments of Venezuela is expected to
pay back 2.8 billion dollars to Goldman
Sachs despite the fact that they only
paid 865 million u.s. dollars for them
and so now you might be wondering well
why does Venezuela accept this deal well
the answer is simply because they need
cash and they need it as soon as
possible seconds they also know they're
never going to pay it back
[Music]
right now you might be wondering well
why did I cus lend them the money if
they know they're not going to get it
back where's the business appeal here so
basically this appeal rise in interest
rates I mean think about it if Venezuela
gives Goldman Sachs 10% of those 2.8
billion every year
that means the bank will have covered
their investments those eight hundred
sixty five million dollars in less than
three years and after that everything's
profit
now of course investors know the
Venezuela is going to default the
question here is when are they going to
do it so investors they're making a
high-risk that it if an escuela keeps
paying for at least four years banks
will win if they don't the banks will
loose and the truth is Nicolas Maduro is
the first one interested in not
declaring bankruptcy on the one hand he
needs to keep bankers on his side so he
can pay his repression machinery on the
other hand PDVSA Venezuela's state-owned
oil company has several properties
abroad
[Music]
factories and refineries in countries
like Haiti and the Dominican Republic
if Caracas defaults some of those
investors might seize them this is why
for several years Venezuela has
prioritized their debt payments over
anything else
murderers foreign currency reserves went
from more than 50 billion dollars to
less than 10 billion and this explains
why a magazine like Forbes said this
about Venezuelan bonds in 2016 Venezuela
might be the worst country in Latin
America but it's barns look great indeed
in the middle of 2017 Donald Trump had
to pass a law banning American banks and
hedge funds from investing in Venezuela
nonetheless no matter how badly Maduro
tried his economy was weaker that he
thought Venezuela to restructure foreign
debt default looms as possibility yes
you had that right goldman sachs and the
rest of those hedge funds who bought
venezuelan bonds at a discount price
they've lost their bet nonetheless there
is still one investor that is far from
being worried and yes well of course
we're talking about China
China's puppet as we said at the
beginning Venezuela is the country that
received the most Chinese money in Latin
America but unlike the private bankers
China's government does not buy bonds on
the market instead Xi Jinping had a
personal meeting with Nicolas Maduro a
meeting where they negotiated a very
special deal alone that is not to be
paid back with money but with oil
this way Beijing makes sure they have an
oil supplier no matter what happens but
hold on a second too because this
formula it's got its drawbacks - as you
know PDVSA is a hyper bureaucratic
company with thousands of workers hired
by shares out of pure nepotism
[Music]
this means oil drilling is harder and
harder for them in fact lately those
dinosaur juice shipments are arriving
pretty late to China but despite all of
that China keeps them loyalty to
Venezuela we are showing solidarity with
the Venezuelan people because we are
supporting the principles of the United
Nations this is what we have to do so
now the question becomes well why what
is China get from Venezuela now that
they are facing problems with their oil
payments well the answer it lies in the
long run just think about it Beijing has
already lent 50 billion dollars to
Caracas now they just need patience and
stability
Midori needs some years to pay back is
dead well no rush preaching mingling
wait however there is something that
could risk the payback of these debts
and that is of changing government what
would happen if the opposition to
Nicolas Maduro took power would they be
willing to meet their obligations to
those who it helps the dictator the one
who sent them to jail and probably
tortured them sounds like a pretty risky
proposition and well risk is the least
favorite word for the Chinese Communist
Party and it explains things like this
one
Venezuela defends purchase of Chinese
riot control gear after more than 70
deaths in street protests China has
already sold over 350 million dollars
worth of weapons to Maduro so that he
can stay in power
thanks to these movements Caracas is
China's biggest ally in the region
basically the Venezuelan government is
to become the puppet of the Chinese
Communist Party so well what happens
well maybe China wants to build new
infrastructure in South America so they
can complete their Silk Road project
well no problem I mean Venezuela
diplomats will support them with no
questions asked maybe China wants to
have a military base in the region well
welcome to Venezuela just like that
they'll get thousands of square miles to
place their army as they please in other
words well there's no better Ally than
the one that needs you in order to
survive
Venezuela hopes no country hinders
China's fantastic Silk Road initiative
nonetheless there is still doubt here
having as much power as they have China
might request other kinds of reforms for
instance if Venezuela keeps facing
problems with their oil payments they
might force Maduro to fire people at
PDVSA and make it more productive they
could even take over the exploitation of
the all themselves
[Music]
so the question here is can Venezuela
become China's colony do you think China
is going to seize Venezuelan oil forever
well we'd love to know your answer and
you can leave it in the comment section
below and if you want to learn more
about how the Venezuelan crisis started
check out our other video and don't
forget to visit reconsider Mediacom
there the podcast that provided the
vocals on this video that are not mine
and as always remember that we publish
brand new videos every week Monday and
Thursday hit that subscribe button to
not miss any post and if you like this
video do give us a thumbs up and as I
always say I'll see you in the next
video and if you want to learn more
about politics and here even more of my
lovely voice you can join us at
reconsider media we have a podcast at
reconsider mediacom slash podcast see
you there
[Music]